[Musique]
depuis plusieurs semaines depuis le
début de la campagne présidentielle
je sillonne notre pays il y est même
rencontré un certain nombre d'entre vous
j'ai vu votre inquiétude
j'ai partagé aux espérances j'ai vu
votre inquiétude de toutes les forces
dont nous disposons il faut maintenant
sortir la france de l'état moral et
matériel où l'on vise les personnes et
la politique qui nous gouvernent depuis
sept ans le désordre est partout il est
dans le chômage
près de deux millions de chômeurs il est
dans la vie chère vous le savez mieux
que personne il est dans une société qui
rejette sa jeunesse le désordre est dans
les difficultés que rencontrent les
personnes âgées dans l'inégalité qui
frappe les femmes au travail et dans la
vie de tous les jours dans
l'impossibilité où se trouvent les uns
d'emprunter les autres de se loger ou de
payer leurs charges locatives
le désordre est dans la disparition de
cent mille exploitations familiales
agricoles dans l'accélération des
faillites --dit liquidation judiciaire
il est dans la façon dont les
travailleurs ouvriers employés cadres
sont tenus à l'écart de la gestion et de
l'information dans leur propre
entreprise
bref le désordre et dans l'injustice la
le privilège et le luxe insolent et de
l'autre côté la grande masse des gens la
plupart des familles qui ont de la peine
à joindre les deux bouts
on nous dit c'est la crise bien entendu
c'est la crise et il est vrai que le
monde occidental a quelques difficultés
à s'adapter aux progrès de la science et
de la technique à faire que l'homme ne
soit pas tout à fait écraser éliminé par
la machine
et pourtant ne nous y trompons pas on ne
sortira pas de la crise par les moyens
jusqu'ici employés
on ne sortira pas de la crise en
demandant les sacrifices toujours aux
mains seul un élan national la volonté
de réveiller les énergies et de donner
leur chance à tous seul un formidable
élan de solidarité nationale nous
permettra de reprendre la route
le corps sans qu'il ose quand ils ne
bougent pas l'eau croupie quand elle ne
coule pas
tout est mouvement dans la vie sept ans
c'était déjà beaucoup et lequel d'entre
vous ne sait pas que 14 ans ce serait
trop j'ai partagé vos espérances
et oui je m'émerveille devant cette
volonté de travail cette capacité de
bien faire j'ai lourds y est encore trop
souvent reliés à ces chaînes chez le
paysan qui connaît le poids des saisons
et des réalités artisans amoureux de
l'objet l'entrepreneur qui crée
l'instituteur qui éveille l'intelligence
de nos enfants je m'émerveille de voir
dans les universités de troisième âge
les anciens chercher à apprendre pour
peu qu'on leur en donne le moyen je
m'émerveille de voir ces jeunes exigent
et rechercher l'harmonie des choses plus
intransigeants que les autres pour la
défense des droits de l'homme oui je le
répète encore je croise aux possibilités
de notre pays à ses talents à son
intelligence et je me dis pourquoi tant
de recul et pourquoi tant d'échecs
c'est sans doute qu'il faut changer de
direction
voilà pourquoi candidats les socialistes
candidats de la gauche seul placé pour
l'emporter j'ai besoin de votre aide
fidèle à mes engagements tels que je les
pratiques depuis plus de 15 ans puisque
j'ai eu le bonheur et la force
d'incarner le rassemblement populaire
je vous le répète je n'écarte personne
et je vous demande seulement de servir
avec moi la grandeur du pays
depuis plusieurs semaines depuis le
début de la campagne présidentielle
je sillonne notre pays il y est même
rencontré un certain nombre d'entre vous
j'ai vu votre inquiétude
j'ai partagé vos espérances j'ai vu
votre inquiétude de toutes les forces
dont nous disposons il faut maintenant
sortir la france de l'état moral et
matériel où l'on vise les personnes et
la politique qui nous gouvernent depuis
sept ans le désordre est partout il est
dans le chômage
près de deux millions de chômeurs il est
dans la vie chère vous le savez mieux
que personne il est dans une société qui
rejette sa jeunesse le désordre est dans
les difficultés que rencontrent les
personnes âgées dans l'inégalité qui
frappe les femmes au travail et dans la
vie de tous les jours dans
l'impossibilité où se trouvent les uns
d'emprunter les autres de se loger ou de
payer leurs charges locatives
le désordre est dans la disparition de
cent mille exploitations familiales
agricoles dans l'accélération des
faillites --dit liquidation judiciaire
il est dans la façon dont les
travailleurs ouvriers employés cadres
sont tenus à l'écart de la gestion et de
l'information dans leur propre
entreprise
bref le désordre et dans l'injustice la
le privilège et le luxe insolent et de
l'autre côté la grande masse des gens la
plupart des familles qui ont de la peine
à joindre les deux bouts
on nous dit c'est la crise bien entendu
c'est la crise et il est vrai que le
monde occidental a quelques difficultés
à s'adapter aux progrès de la science et
de la technique à faire que l'homme ne
soit pas tout à fait écraser éliminé par
la machine
et pourtant ne nous y trompons pas on ne
sortira pas de la crise par les moyens
jusqu'ici employés
on ne sortira pas de la crise en
demandant les sacrifices toujours aux
mains seul un élan national la volonté
de réveiller les énergies et de donner
leur chance à tous seul un formidable
élan de solidarité nationale nous
permettra de reprendre la route le corps
sont qu'il ose quand ils ne bougent pas
l'eau croupie quand elle ne coule pas
tout est mouvement dans la vie sept ans
c'était déjà beaucoup et lequel d'entre
vous ne sait pas que 14 ans ce serait
trop j'ai partagé vos espérances
et oui je m'émerveille devant cette
volonté de travail cette capacité de
bien faire chez les lourds y est encore
trop souvent reliés à ces chaînes chez
le paysan qui connaît le poids des
saisons et des réalités artisans
amoureux de l'objet l'entrepreneur qui
crée l'instituteur qui éveille
l'intelligence de nos enfants je
m'émerveille de voir dans les
universités de troisième âge les anciens
chercher à apprendre pour peu qu'on leur
en donne le moyen je m'émerveille de
voir ces jeunes exigent et rechercher
l'harmonie des choses plus
intransigeants que les autres pour la
défense des droits de l'homme
oui je le répète encore je croise aux
possibilités de notre pays à ses talents
à son intelligence et je me dis pourquoi
tant de recul et pourquoi dans l'échec
c'est sans doute qu'il faut changer de
direction
voilà pourquoi candidats les socialistes
et candidats de la gauche seul placé
pour l'emporter j'ai besoin de votre
aide
fidèle à mes engagements tels que je les
pratiques depuis plus de 15 ans puisque
j'ai eu le bonheur et la force
d'incarner le rassemblement populaire
je vous le répète je n'écarte personne
et je vous demande seulement de servir
avec moi la grandeur du pays
[Musique]